[Music]
in a world where most movies are just
okay one film will be so bizarre so
upsetting and so aggressively bad the
sheer amount of suck will collapse in on
itself like a dying star and explode in
a supernova of unintentional genius the
room Tommy Wiseau
stars in Rights produces and directs a
film that puts the passion in passion
project
financed by a rumored six million
dollars of his own mysterious fortune
and featuring three long minutes of his
own mysterious butt cheeks he's a man
with a singular vision a unique personal
style and a powerful message to share
with the world maybe it's okay to give
up on your dreams how can they say this
about me I don't believe it I showed
them journey to b-roll of San Francisco
and meet Johnny your everyday
all-american Dracula you know people
don't have to say it they can feel it
sometimes his emotions run hot
you got Tammy part Lisa sometimes he's
so cold it's like he forgets he's on
camera but he always finds time to laugh
at the little things
anything for my princess or laugh for no
particular reason
or laugh at things you really shouldn't
be laughing at one of them found out
about it beat her up so bad she ended up
in a hospital in Carrero street dude
what part of that is funny experience a
story that at its core is a really
simple love triangle where Johnny is
engaged to Lisa his wife of the future
you might future wife Lisa's your future
wife after all she's my future wife but
she doesn't love him I don't love Johnny
anymore I don't love him anymore I don't
love him anymore but I don't love him
so she sleeps with Mark his best friend
Johnny's my best friend Johnny's my best
friend he's my best friend
I know he's your best friend but set
that aside because the room has an of
dangling plot threads to weave a blanket
like this endless unexplained game of
tuxedo football Johnny's promotion at
whatever his job is these two friends
who randomly appear and disappear
throughout the movie this drug deal
that's never mentioned again and the
most casual eye of cancer of all time I
got the results of the tests back I
definitely have breast cancer you are
you gonna react to that no okay cool
cool
most movies cut straight to the
interesting parts but the room is not
most movies where if a man makes a tape
you get to see him set up the equipment
[Music]
if two friends have lunch you see what
everyone in front of them ordered she's
gonna copy okay once you guys have a
seat we'll have that right out for you
hi how you doing what would you like
yeah it sounds good once you guys have a
seat we'll have a right out for you oh
hi Susan
oh hi Johnny and if a man gives us
Beyonce flowers you'll see exactly how
that financial transaction went down
spoiler alert it was weird how much is
this it'll be $18 go keep the change
hi doggy you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye do you like sex well
not for long because you're about to
watch an alien's approximation of human
lovemaking where a little man playing a
little boy tries to join a threesome
three's a crowd these two randoms act
like toddlers while they do it
and Johnny does his best to penetrate
the area around Lisa's bellybutton just
close your eyes when the arm becomes on
trust us so enjoy this real-life version
of springtime for Hitler that's the
pinnacle of so bad it's good filmmaking
spawning midnight movie screenings Oscar
caliber films about its creation and the
enduring mystery of who Tommy Wiseau is
where he's from where his money comes
from and how old he is but some
mysteries are probably better left
unsolved we've seen the guys tanked I
don't need to know anymore
starring football spoon art entrances
and exits oh hey guys I have to go now
I've got to go oh hi Mike there you go
oh hi mark
I have to go oh hi Danny I have to go
sir I better be going oh hi Peter I
gotta go oh hi Danny
I gotta go Oh
don't worry don't worry don't worry
don't worry about it don't worry about
it don't worry about it don't worry
about Johnny he's just being a big baby
generalizing about women women changed
their minds all the time you think girls
like did she like guys do I never say
what they mean and they always play
games sometimes are just too smart
sometimes just flat-out stupid other
times they're just evil falling for no
reason Lisa doesn't want to talk about
it I don't want to talk about it I don't
want to talk about it I don't want to
talk about it I don't want to talk about
it I don't want to talk about it
focus focus focus and chicken chicken
ChIP chip chip chip chip chip chip chip
chip chip the room not room the room
very different
I like to think Lisa's mom isn't playing
a character she's just a lady he
wandered in and started commenting on
what she saw
what are these characters doing here how
many people come in and out of this
apartment every day this is worse than
Grand Central Station you're my favorite
customer leave your stupid comments in
your pocket I got the results of the
tests back I definitely have breast
cancer you're tearing me apart Lisa I
did not hit her it's not true it's
[__]
I did not hit her I did not oh hi mark